bonne journée signoret week tchaoudjo
ravi de vous revoir à rome a gardé
bisogno dynamite au louvre oui en effet
quaranta novais dites moi monsieur x est
pour une soirée officielle ou plutôt
mondaine mondaine et c'est pour la
soirée ou aussi pour la journée j'en
veux un pour la journée et a pour la
soirée qu'elle steed italia il ya deux
boutons de le pantalon fuselé et la
doublure quel genre tactique disque de
carbure de silicium matrice céramique
avec stratifié à toute épreuve ce qu'ils
ont fait une véritable armure que nous
causons entre la doublure et le tissu ça
peut être faire une urgence mais
naturellement
où voulez vous que ce soit libre et à
l'hôtel
[Musique]
tu aurais dit
qu'à cela
du travail
oui
et toi
oui mais
on
bonne soirée
j'ai bien peur que
ça me désole de dons possibles
[Musique]
je voudrais voir le directeur quel
plaisir de vous revoir sitôt monsieur
eric dois-je vous annoncer oui s'il vous
plaît restez
monsieur week est là et veut vous voir
monsieur
il vient d'offrir 7 millions de dollars
pour votre vie et sept millions de
dollars c'est une sacrée somme d'argent
dessus week
alors je crois que vous avez le choix
vous voulez une guerre où vous allez
juste me donner une arme au port pitié
que quelqu'un donne à cet homme une arme
alors je prends votre descente aux
enfers commence ici monsieur week
alors on va vous y conduire faites
attention lors de la descente
n'oubliez pas que vous avez une dette
envers moi ce n'est pas dans votre
intérêt
si john rythme n'est pas encore
ça ne tardera pas la poignarder le
diable dans le dos pour thor il est
toujours là du travail
j'ai bien peur que oui qik ce soir
je les tuerai tous
[Musique]
quel plaisir de vous revoir civique
monsieur week
j'ai besoin de toi pour ce contrat je ne
suis plus cette place si tu es toujours
cette âme là je ne devrais pas tu
connais les règles si tu ne respectes
pas tu connais les conséquences
comptes créditeurs comment puis-je vous
aider je voudrais ouvrir un compte à
quel nom john wick contrat est devenu
international
tu n'as aucune idée de ce qui varie
[Musique]
par pitié quelqu'un donne à cet homme
une arme
faire sonner leurs cours tu a poignardé
le diable dans le dos ou pour lui il ne
s'agit pas de vengeance mais de justice
du travail j'ai bien peur que oui
keep ce soit je les tuerai
je les tuerai tous bien sûr que oui
voilà
je vais essayer mais je promets rien
[Musique]